Apple has recently made some huge
changes to the MacBook lineup and a lot
of you may be wondering what exactly is
different between each MacBook and which
one is the right fit for you so today
we've got apples complete lineup of 2019
mac books right here in the office which
should mostly say the same into 2020
we've got the MacBook Air for $1100
we've got the base 13-inch MacBook Pro
for $1300 the higher-end 13-inch Pro for
$1,800 and the 15-inch MacBook Pro for
$2,400 and if you're watching this video
a couple of months after I made it
chances are there also may be a 16 inch
macbook pro available but as of today
July 27 2009 teen it's still only a
rumor and it's gonna be a very high-end
laptop like over $3,000 at the base
price so it'll be in a league of its own
but if you're curious about that model
check out our channel for videos on that
now let's get started with comparing
literally everything we can between all
these Mac books starting with
portability the air is the lightest at
just 2.75 pounds but it's hardly
noticeable compared to the three-pound
13-inch pro from above the air is
basically just as large as a 13-inch
MacBook Pro so portability should be
pretty similar and much more portable
than the 15-inch the MacBook Pros also
have more of a flat slate shape compared
to the MacBook Air which has a wedge
design that gets thinner near the front
end each of these Mac books has a high
quality retina resolution display but
the AERS display isn't as nice it's
quite a bit dimmer than the pros that
each have an incredible 500 nits of
brightness and it's definitely not as
color accurate since every MacBook Pro
has P 3 wide color gamut which has about
25% more colors than 100% srgb which is
a must-have for photo editors as far as
display sharpness they all have the same
retina quality 227 pixels per inch and
this year every MacBook and the lineup
finally comes with true tone technology
which adjusts the white balance of the
display to match the environment around
you speaker quality and volume is a huge
deal for some people especially to me so
here's the sound comparisons you can
hear the differences for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
we noticed that the air has slightly
worse speakers than the base search and
inch pro but volumes sound quality and
bass go way up with the $1,800 13-inch
Pro as well as the 15-inch model so if
speaker quality matters to you you
should consider the higher-end models
however the air sounds better and louder
than almost every Windows laptop we've
tested now on to the keyboards they're
all packing Apple's latest
fourth-generation butterfly keys that
have new key switch materials which
should be more reliable than before and
we've yet to hear of any issues with the
ports on keyboard but even if you do all
these Mac books come with a 4-year free
keyboard replacement warranty if you
have any issues with the keys apart from
that the MacBook Airs keyboard slopes
downward towards the front edge so it's
actually a bit more comfortable to type
on compared to the pros and this year
every single macbook in the line-up
comes with the touch ID sensor built
into the power button which makes it
really convenient to log in use Apple
pay online and install apps off the web
without having to enter your password
every macbook pro this year comes with
the touch bar an OLED display that
replaces the top row of keys and is
fully customizable however not many
people like it because it's more
difficult to do things like adjust
display brightness volume and use the
Escape key I personally don't really
like the touch bar but it's not that big
of a deal and this year every macbook
also comes with a t2 chip which helps
with security and provides Hardware
transcoding of heb see video footage and
now let's talk about the ports every
port on every map book this year
supports Thunderbolt 3 but both the
13-inch MacBook Air and the lower and
MacBook Pro come with only two of these
ports compared to four ports on the more
expensive pros if you're a basic user
that doesn't really connect to external
displays storage drives or external
devices very often you'll probably be
just fine with one of the two port
models and you also have the choice of
buying a Thunderbolt 3 hub just in case
you do need more ports but having 4
ports from the get-go is definitely more
convenient especially for those who use
those ports often now if you love large
trackpads the 15-inch pro has the
biggest one of them all followed by the
13-inch pro and then the MacBook Air
which has a slightly smaller trackpad
but is still larger than most Windows
laptops for battery life the new MacBook
Air is rated at 12 hours compared to 10
hours on the MacBook
so if battery life is what you're after
the air is the best option and if you
love maxing out the brightness on your
display like I do you could see an even
bigger difference since the air has a
dimmer display and finally let's talk
about performance starting with the
processors this year at the base 13 inch
MacBook Pro finally gets a quad-core
processor so the MacBook Air is now the
only one in the lineup with a dual-core
CPU the $1,800 MacBook Pro has a quad
core and the 15-inch pro has a 6 core
that can actually be upgraded to an 8
core if you're willing to spend $2,800
looking at RAW processing performance
using Geekbench force multi-core test we
can see that the MacBook Air with its
dual-core CPU is way behind the MacBook
Pros and surprisingly the $1300 pro
performs almost the same as the $1,800
model and the 15-inch gives you a pretty
good jump in performance as well so we
decided to look at performance per
dollar using the full retail price of
each macbook and the new $1300 based
macbook pro comes out way ahead with
incredible amounts of raw power for the
cache with the air being a very bad
value performance wise one thing that
you won't find on the spec sheet is that
the $1300 based MacBook Pro has only one
fan just like on the MacBook Air while
the more expensive $1,800 and $2,400
pros have duel fans something like this
could definitely impact performance for
longer workloads so we also ran
Cinebench R 20 a more realistic
benchmark which is long enough to heat
up the systems and see how well the
cooling system works and surprisingly
the single fan on the $1300 pro didn't
really limit performance like we thought
it would so we're really impressed with
it however we noticed that while the
dual fans on the higher-end models were
louder at first they eventually slowed
down a little bit as the system
stabilized but the single fan models
kept running at full blast until the end
of the test so the dual fan models will
probably be quieter overall we also
tested SSD speeds and here we see a
pretty big difference when going to the
more expensive MacBook Pros but even the
less expensive models are still fast
enough for most people especially basic
users so there you have it there are all
the 2018 MacBooks compared and if you're
still confused on which macbook you
should buy let me break it down for you
the $1300 based 13-inch MacBook Pro is
by far
the best value you can get in terms of
performance and overall MacBook
experience but if you don't really need
a great display or high performance and
you'd rather save a couple hundred bucks
you can definitely go for the MacBook
Air instead the air is great if you're a
writer a student or someone who just
wants a premium reliable laptop for
doing basic computer tasks like web
browsing working with documents and
sometimes watching some Netflix as well
as getting some extra battery life out
of it
so for basic use the MacBook Air will be
the best option for you now if you're
doing any kind of professional tasks
like photo editing video editing 3d
animation or anything like that and you
love having the best display you can get
with better speakers in the air then I
would highly recommend going for the
$1,300 MacBook Pro instead it's the best
value macbook we've ever seen now the
$1,800 13-inch MacBook Pro is for those
people who have a bit more cash left in
their budget and are willing to spend it
to get a few more luxury improvements
like an extra two Thunderbolt three
ports better speakers faster storage
speeds slightly faster performance and
two cooling fans which should lead to an
overall quieter laptop during heavy
workloads now all of those things aren't
really deal-breakers but if they matter
to you you should consider that model it
already comes with 256 gigs of storage
so in reality it's $300 more than the
base model with a matching SSD and
finally the 15-inch MacBook Pro is for
those who know that they need the extra
performance from the six core CPU are
even upgrading to the eight core and if
you're a serious 4k or raw Video Editor
this is the one again since it has
dedicated graphics and it's also the
only model that can come with 32 gigs of
ram so it's great for high-end photo
editors or programmers it's for the
people who want the absolute best with
the biggest trackpad the best speakers
the biggest display and the highest
performance you can get and to finish
this video off here are some general
purchasing recommendations if you're
anything more than a basic user we'd
recommend getting at least 256 gigabytes
of storage and if you're working with
professional tasks almost every day we'd
also recommend getting 16 gigabytes of
RAM especially if you're a photo editor
we also recommend that you never upgrade
the processor unless you're getting
extra cores out of the deal which is
only available on the 15 inch going from
6 cores
eight-course upgrading from an i5 to an
i7 doesn't change anything
other than a slight performance boost
which almost always isn't worth the
price and if you're a very serious Video
Editor get the best graphics you can
afford especially the Vega 20 graphics
and for photo editors graphics will do
basically nothing for you so you should
focus on RAM first and then the
processor and if the 16 inch MacBook Pro
is out already check out one of those
two videos right there to see is
comparing it to the 15-inch model if
this video helps you out
tap the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]